[Music]
mirror verse news submitted by locked
and loaded scientists are searching for
evidence of a mirror universe yeah bro
smoke if you got it mirror yudish it's
trippy if you've got stranger things
like yeah is this expanding upon the
parallel universe theory yes okay
University of course in eastern
Tennessee there's a physicist who's
trying to open a portal into a parallel
universe portal bores straight up
stranger than I'm not that bored what if
but stuff comes out of there or what if
good stuff comes out of cancer wait but
like does she have any basis to even
think she could do this no she's a quack
she calls it an oscillation right which
would lead to mirror matter but the idea
is basically that they're gonna run a
series of experiments where they're
gonna send a beam of subatomic particles
down a 50-foot tunnel past a powerful
magnet and into an impenetrable wall and
if the setup is just right and they do
it exactly the way that they're planning
on doing it some of these particles are
gonna transform into what are called
mirror image versions of themselves how
do they find that out she watched
stranger things [ __ ] no but like how
so they did these prior experiments
where they're calculating I guess the
lifetime of these neutrons and sometimes
they just disappear out of nowhere I
know that's as far as I go yeah and it's
like wait how can they disappear so
where the hell did they go if it's in
such a container space mmm so if they're
gonna send it down this impenetrable
walls where this is so important if this
wall is impenetrable and they recount
the neutrons if they do disappear they
went somewhere then maybe the mirror
universe yeah it's like you're jerking
off and you come right but then some of
your comm is gone and you're like where
did it go it evaporated no but but for
years everyone's been like wait where
does a comb go like not all the [ __ ] is
still here yeah you hear a fart and you
don't smell it you're like we're too far
go see mirror universe
it appeared into the ether I just keep
thinking of dr. strange in like Marvel
Universe it is like that so that's
that's the the theory by now right so
these particles in a lot of what we
understand so far weird we don't
understand where they go or what they do
like a lot of current theory in physics
is super strange like when you get to
the subatomic level particles just exist
and then stop existing and then go away
you have the idea behind this is maybe
they're not going away per se they're
going into another alternate universe
that exists in parallel to our own
and then what's next we're gonna shoot
humans at this impenetrable wall to see
if they can go into this era actually
yes we're gonna shoot small people they
could fit in the cannon yes if we find
out the of these neutrons are
disappearing and going to this universe
that is not good news these neutrons are
so small but what if we could open a
portal that's almost like what's
happening here is like it's almost like
you're opening a portal into it by by
shooting this beam at this wall you're
sending these particles into that year
when does this happen it only happens in
these circumstances we don't really know
question for that lady cuz I'm like how
did you know this was even like when is
it that they they disappear so a bunch
of other experiments that weren't based
off this when they started figuring out
that neutrons happened disappearing is
when they're like wait what the [ __ ] so
usually I think they would consider most
under physical rules like where what
that were the possibility where they can
go but because it's been happening so
much they're like okay we got to
consider some things we haven't been
considering before that's outside of the
physics that we understand like in there
in the 1990s they developed this
high-precision
experiment to study how neutrons which
are part of the nuclei of atoms right
they break down into protons which is
related to radioactivity but then the
experiments got weird because they found
that the neutrons created in particle
beams which are similar to the ones that
we're talking about right now they last
14 minutes and 48 seconds on average
before decaying into protons but
neutrons stored in the laboratory
bottles seem to break down faster 14
minutes 38 seconds so 10 second
difference which is a lot and that
doesn't sound like a lot right but the
differ
should be nothing because all neutrons
are exactly the same and their behavior
should not depend at all on where
they're being examined and one of the
basal a simulation theory were like
we're living in a simulation is that
they would shoot these was it protons or
neutrons neutrons into a wall or with
with something that's blocking it or
screen right so when it's not being
observed it's like at random and then
when it is being observed it's directly
into a straight line so they're saying
like human observation has something to
do with the way that they activate how
do they know they're being observed so
when we are observing these subatomic
particles they for some reason show up
and then when we stop observing them
they dissipate I don't know how they
know but it's like a video game where
like you know as you're going through
like the world right things pop up and
all these things are created and then
when you're not there that area the game
is resting literally if you turn around
in a video game crate all the things
behind you just broke down so they can
power what's in front it's like the
Matrix movie where the guy could only
turn invisible when no one's looking at
him but then how do you know he's
[ __ ] invisible like how do you know
that like with colors colors only have
are only a color when you shine light on
them so if a bathroom a NAT orange and
the lights are off it the walls aren't
orange yeah yeah so you need the light
in order for it to come bring the colors
out I still think it's their orange but
yes what color is it an intrinsic thing
to the matter you're looking at it's
just the reflection of the spectrum of
light that's being shine on it and the
color can change depending on the light
so back to what's called a mirror
universe right there like ten years ago
this guy in Russia introduced the idea
that ordinary neutrons sometimes cross
over into what's called a mirror world
and transform into mirror neutrons right
well you just use lots of we probably
yeah nah too high listening to this day
I'm like this really hurting my brain
giggles I don't know what
think I think like good there's people
on the other side here and then people
were like wow well he seems smart let's
put a million dollars into the research
yeah Wow
that's Elizabeth Holmes that's how she
got funding is that right I didn't know
anything this is why I don't think that
government like the governor's not
telling us about aliens and [ __ ] cuz my
brain can't handle this right now you're
going through overload right now
government matching us is like just
making it so we're not we don't have to
think about it at home orange in the
black and that [ __ ] blue is that real
now imagine what religions being
challenged because of it right like we
were made in Amman and God's image yeah
that goes away if alien life exists he
looks like you oh my god it's like
Alanis Morissette no no whatever you're
whoever's looking at him he looks like
that man dinner it's just you're looking
out a mirror dude that's crazy pretty
interesting so there's another theory to
that dark matter which we don't really
understand at all but we know that it
comprises a huge percentage of what the
universe is actually made out of right
another theory is that that dark matter
is actually an alternate universe that's
just around us and that we can there's a
log line on dark matter dark matter is
super it has its own gravitational pull
to it in between space it's it's around
everything it's around everything so
like around the earth right now it would
it's almost like a big spider's web that
shoots out all around the entire
universe and it keeps it sort of keeps
everything moving together like you know
how we move in orbit with all of our all
the planets the solar system they dark
matter seems to be some kind of gigantic
spider web that keeps everything kind of
congealed it's an immeasurable matter so
like I think like with electromagnetic
equipment like gravity even bends light
in space right but it's with dark matter
because it doesn't Bend light so you
can't really tell that there's something
there but with there are calculations of
all these astral bodies of the way the
gravitational forces that they do have
all these planets and stars should be
shooting away from each other because of
the gravitational force but there is
something that is
that I'm shooting away from each other
and they they're calling that Dark
Matter it's often the people they can't
measure often depicted is like a big
spider black dark spider wedding the
easiest way to maybe explain is the
negative space between me and you it's
to stop in between the plan yeah no no
it doesn't have anything to do with that
it's like atoms right if I say that
people are gonna kill me but it's like
if I try to break it down into layman's
I think it's the in-between space of the
emptiness so it's the empty if it's
there it's what where where there is a
lot of that's right if there's two
planets did dad through their
calculation should be flying away from
each other but for some reason it's it's
held there then they're like let's if
you have two magnets right if it's both
South Poles pointing at each other they
should fly away from each other but for
some reason it's staying there
then from them to like ocean there's
probably dark matter there's something
that's overriding that gravitational
isn't it the advancement of Newton's
theory on gravity where he believed that
gravity was from the mass and then dark
matter is like this next level of what
gravity is mono no body no all matter
has its own gravitational force okay
well I I'm not all matter yeah no matter
how small how big but the biggest are
gases considered matter yes so that it's
just a very like Airy matter ok so then
that we don't have dark matter here them
because there are gases in the
atmosphere they are saying that the dark
matter is out into space like yeah yeah
cuz here like we everything can be
dictated by common physics like I can
predict if you're to run towards me how
much when that's gonna push to the side
how the leaves are gonna Bend like we
can calculate all those things that
things that are defined their physical
calculations in the universe they they
they they use dark matter as a way to
kind of explain that like why aren't
these things flying away from each other
well I understand why we think as a
mirror why isn't it just another what
like why do they think the neutrons are
disappearing into a mirror universe not
just another cooler universe or like
what if it just by mere disappears what
you just described is right right like
it goes to a maybe a
universe or worse universe but that is
I'm your universe right because it's
still here because it still are a
depiction of our reality but that is
slightly different they don't call it a
different dimension they call it a
mirror which is kind of confusing I
don't know I don't know about I exist in
the mirror universe I think so I think
you're a brunette though I think maybe
you're a blonde over there then what do
you let's go there what if there's
another mirror universe where I'm
actually sitting there and you're
sitting there and you're sitting there
oh wow right
is this like these are things that we
need to know like we're spending I
wanted nurses to find I can't handle
them you've been another universe Joe
sitting over there I know I want to know
that we let's put our brain power to
matter think more videos ago I said I
think we're already way too smart than
we need to be but imagine all the things
that week maybe we'll discover through
this sort of disaster
maybe the cure for cancer is over there
the cure for users for sure here or
maybe through this we'll find some
really cool foot cream no we didn't know
[Music]
[Music]